[Music] Sometimes
poison becomes non-toxic in this world.
For example, eel is originally poisonous, but it
can be eaten by draining its blood or heating it. In the case of this seaweed, you can soak it in recycled water.  What I
prepared here is one that has been soaked in incision water and
one that hasn't.What are you
doing?I guess it's
okay.Don't worry.O
says this on his own.Nana
[Music]
Yes.  I was planning on eating it to see if it could be made non-toxic by soaking it overnight, but then I
changed my mind and here's the problem.Who suggested it?If
the person who ordered it was the one who ate it, then in a sense it was their fault.  I understand,
but if that's not the case, then
it's only natural that it's more dangerous if you order it from a region where people don't have the custom of eating it. I get it, the people here are smart. There's
no need to say anything more.
[Music]